uh no I brought a pen I got a pen
all right
good morning everybody
okay
doctors
yeah okay
right why I actually have a sort of a
doctor's appointment myself at three
o'clock I have to go to Bow to get my
new inserts from my shoes
and he tells me to bring he just says
bring all your shoes I had this giant
laundry thing and and just as I was
getting into my car I looked up and
there was my golf clubs you know my golf
shoes and I said better bring those too
to make sure that the insertion so
okay all right
all right we're doing health insurance
all right first up is HB 343 relative to
billing for ambulance services
so I got the email I got
um from
um I think it was ncsl was their
somewhat model legislation
and
and it would have been nice but I
started reading like a
how did this one fly but it didn't solve
the what I have found is the the biggest
problem we've had with it is that the
ambulance companies want
to balance bill
that that's that was the pushback we
were getting and I think there was on
even on your side of the aisle was that
some some of the fire departments they
want to be able to to to do that back
billing so but well we got Joyce you're
right on with that uh the Fire Chiefs um
are not in favor of having us take away
their ability to get some extra money
um so that is is PR we don't want
balanced building because that's a
concern it's not technically about
that's consumer issue but um up North
this is really a rural problem it's
really yes absolutely
um we're we're facing a situation where
um the small towns can't afford to
maintain an ambulance and also to staff
it so so
um there is a possibility of well we've
had a we floated a few ideas like
um doing a pool of money with fees to
help the people who can't afford it or
combining towns together
uh but each town is about 10 square
miles so if you happen to be on there
we're really straight out and you have a
heart attack it could take an hour for
the ambulance to get to you
um so this is I I think looking at what
NCL and and CSL whatever it is
um whatever they come up with is a good
idea because this is going on in Montana
and Iowa and all of the states that have
rural populations
um now uh I think that the bill that we
worked on with all the different
possibilities for amendments is pretty
much
um shredded at this point but Anita has
offered to kind of pick up the the torch
on that along with some other people do
you want to speak to it Jenny
yeah I mean I think the most significant
thing that I learned I I talked to and
her name is is escaping me at this point
from New Hampshire Hospital Association
she said this bill is way too
complicated and you are never going to
get from last time
but
[Laughter]
um she said you're not going to get it
passed as is but maybe break it down and
I thought that was a brilliant idea so
so you know I think that that's the way
to go is for us to to to go to something
smaller
um again as as Joy said that would
impact this maybe help the smaller towns
that might be the way to go right okay
and
thanks Mr chair
um
anybody that does bring forth the
legislation too there was a study
committee four summers ago I think it
was there's a lot of information from
testimony from stakeholders and that
should maybe in this report we can kind
of um just reference that so that people
know where to go to get some of the
information so they don't have to
reinvent you know all the way from the
beginning but it would
it's a very complicated issue there
aren't any easy answers the insurance
companies have got to be part of this
and um but the report should reflect
that we've had a study I can't remember
if it was a committee or commission so
who Joyce are you guys
who should make the motion then
um
I would recommend that this has further
legislation oh further well no no future
has a future this bill I think we should
just yeah that's what I'm saying I don't
know basically we want to send the
message that this language yeah it's not
probably you can write in your saying is
that we still think this needs to be
resolved but this bill is not
recommended yeah I'll be happy to do
that okay could we ask can we hear from
Paula just briefly of course come on up
Paul
so while she's coming up I want to let
you all know that uh as a member of
Cheshire county we are now going to be a
little more intimately involved in this
issue because the county has taken its
rapid funds and is now offering the
ambulance services for all our small
towns so I'll I'll be even more plugged
into what the issues are here uh but I
kept saying to them I said uh you do
know there's a problem you know out
there and they were a key you know
keenly aware of it so hopefully but it
was the hospital or the hospital was
really concerned about the ambulance
service that we had in Keene and they
were very happy that we did this
good morning Paul good morning chairman
hunt um for the record Paula minahan
Hospital Association
um and thank you for the opportunity to
answer any questions or speak but I I do
believe it is a rural issue as
representative Burroughs and I discuss
and I know um representative Weston and
I have discussed this in the past I
one idea is to bring the stakeholders
together
now and talk through this and I think
the municipal association should be part
of this because it is an issue for towns
and I don't know that they have been
involved
um but maybe there is a solution or a
targeted solution
for the um for the volunteer
groups you know throughout the rural
areas of the state because I think it
really is a rule issue primarily I'm not
certainly an expert on this but like you
said
chairman hunt to the extent that the
hospitals are involved sometimes they um
they I mean obviously they know when
there are problems when they can't have
access to
um prompt EMS services so they certainly
are care about this issue a lot they
just don't necessarily have a financial
stake in these services but they
certainly care about them because they
they provide services to their
facilities
and and I know that you've been around
and Paula I think is probably Paul and I
have both been around this this uh his
track many many many times but um the
you know the fundamental problem is that
these ambulance companies don't want to
sign contracts with the insurance
companies right right so that again
that's to the that was why I made the
comment that this is complicated because
it's it is um there are a lot of factors
well that's why I was arguing this is
like a balanced billing problem which is
those right those those uh practitioners
that weren't signing contracts with
insurance companies right no I and I do
recall
um representative Bartlett morning I
remember that that study committee as
well and I'm sure
um Paula Rogers recalls it as well I'm
sure I have a file on it somewhere back
at the office yeah so I you're right
there is some good information that came
out of that and I'm sure archives if
it's not on gen Court I'm sure archives
has it but they probably it probably is
in archives because I was thinking
summer 2016. does that sound right
I possibly it goes back a while yeah it
does
yeah you're right yeah um and like Paul
is right there were periodic discussions
about this um but it was always 20 years
ago I mean I feel like I first time
we've had this was yeah even when you
first started getting had your job at
the end of ideas I remember it was one
of the first times so it's it's been
over 20 years this is not around
so
okay okay anybody else one more time
anybody yes representative uh thank you
I just want to
um say again and remind everyone that
this is an issue of of extreme
importance to the Lincoln Woodstock
Ambulance Service which is a volunteer
Service uh
um I don't know what uh 503 it is but it
is independent from uh the towns of the
fire department but it's a very small
service and without the ability to back
Bill a lot of our business we're ski
town a lot of our business is out of
Staters
um and can be uh fairly expensive a
rescue missions so they need the ability
to backfill and I'm sure the director of
that service or anyone would be willing
to serve on any kind of a committee or
certainly give feedback as to how
important it is to Lincoln and Woodstock
do you agree representative ham that it
would be the municipal Association that
probably would be a good
stakeholder to reach out to I I do
believe okay that would be
um a good uh resource because many times
it is a an arm of the municipality Yeah
in our case it is not oh okay okay but I
agree that they probably should have
some input okay thank you
okay yes representative Burroughs I
wanted to ask publicly if representative
Hamm would join me in working on this I
I asked I would be honored to I'd be
pleased to thank you
perfect okay anybody else
all right so representative Wesson will
move that uh we we hope that something
will come in the future but at this
point this particular Bill uh in this
form cannot work all right uh Senate
Bill 287 relative to pounds billing for
certain Health Care Services
maybe not then we solve Health then we
solve balance building what did this
bill do anybody anybody remember what
this bill did what's this one
somebody help me out okay come on up
Michelle Heaton from the New Hampshire
insurance department this was a bill
originally brought on behalf of the
insurance department what we were trying
to do is there's the national no
surprises act that solves a lot of the
balance billing issues what this bill is
trying to do is take a lot of what's in
the no surprises act and put it into New
Hampshire law where we got held up last
term was over
um the dispute resolution mechanism
right under no surprises act there's a
federal dispute resolution right process
and then that was being challenged in
court the court throughout part of it
since and our bill what we were
proposing is take out that National
process and instead use the process that
we already have projects right where the
commissioner would determine what the
commercially reasonable rate is
right um since then
of the feds have redone the rules to
address the issue that came up in the
court so that's kind of where we're at
but the Department's position is we
still think this bill is good and
important and we'd like to see it too in
its current form
um
I think there was an amendment we were
going to propose at some point but this
is
the version I think we initially wanted
there were some amendments that we were
talking about but then it ended up
getting
um expedient to legislate so those I
don't think happened no it's not exp
this is interim study so yeah interim we
didn't kill it yeah completely it went
interim study so not all of them that we
had been discussing at the time
necessarily made it in but I think the
current version is the version that the
department would be most in favor of
okay but in addition to the dispute
resolution process there's some other
stuff in here that's also helps align
New Hampshire statutes but no surprises
act the dispute resolution process with
just one part okay remind me who who you
are you you have your Michelle heat and
I'm the health you're the new okay law
and policy legal counsel okay
all right
um
I guess my memory was that the insurance
companies were concerned about these two
different statutes conflicting with each
other was it something like that or
thank you
providers had a problem the providers or
anybody here for the providers
but of course the hospital Association
thank you very much Michelle
hello again
um Paula from the hospital Association
Paul I'm in the hand um we so the
version that actually crossed over from
the Senate to here is a amended version
um that we were supportive of because it
took out the dispute the controversial
parts and um Michelle's right their
dispute resolution is what we were
concerned about
um we also do not believe this bill is
necessary because we have the federal no
surprises act legislation and there is a
federal dispute resolution process
outlined and Michelle's also right um
that there are new rules that came out
as a result of some of the questions and
concerns raised at the federal level so
our position remains that we don't
believe this is necessary and what is
important to note is the consumer is
protected from balance billing that is
right now they're protected that we
without this bill so we don't believe
this bill is that's our position that we
don't believe this bill is necessary and
we do have concerns about having the
dispute resolution
um
retained and ultimately with one
individual in the department of
insurance not that we have anything to
against the commissioner it's just the
um the structure is problematic for
providers since we are not the hospitals
and the providers are not regulated by
the Department of Insurance
okay so you're saying you would rather
have the federal statute than the state
statute when it comes to disputes
at this point yes unless we were able to
um and we did we tried we had multiple
meetings with the department and the
carriers and some of the legislators
um during in the Senate discussions so
some of the Senators to try to get to a
position where we could all agree but we
just couldn't get to that point but
again the important thing is without
this bill the consumer is protected from
balance billing because of the federal
law so that's our that's why we don't
believe it's necessary
uh I guess I'll play The Devil's
Advocate on this and that is as long as
the federal law is out there then the
state law is you anyways
no says Michelle
yeah why don't you come up
the way the no surprise of the Act was
um drafted is a lot of States including
New Hampshire had some bound spilling
projections already in place okay so if
a state has laws regarding balance
billing the state law will apply if they
don't have something on the books to
cover a specific situation then the
federal law applies so in a way it's a
reverse preemption almost but it's to
preserve state laws that were already in
place but the more protective law is
going to apply so what we're trying to
do is make it so the New Hampshire
insurance department has more authority
over surprise billing so when something
isn't going as it should we don't have
to wait for the federal government to
take action and the department would be
in a better position to help enforce
some of those Provisions yeah I guess I
would lean to say yes I think having it
closer to home is a better resolution
system
I guess my concern is is it would is
uh is there a con confusion because the
two of them are out there and that you
know when things get bogged down over
just a debate on on who really has
jurisdiction whether it's the federal or
the state
so right now
it has jurisdiction because we do
already have a balanced Building Law
right not applies to certain things so
depending on which situation there's the
whole analysis we need to go through
right now to say well does the
department have jurisdiction does the
federal government have to jurisdiction
it needs to be clarified yeah and part
other parts of this that are included um
prohibit providers and give oplc for
example the authority and the boards to
discipline providers who are violating
the balance billing laws whereas right
now it's the federal government that
would have to do that which is a much
lengthier process okay so have we had
any cases yet
so federally there have been about 40
000 cases have gone through no I mean in
New Hampshire in New Hampshire we have
not so we it doesn't matter it's whether
it's state or federal we haven't had any
cases at all we have had consumer
complaints a couple of them about bound
spilling instances but no one has used
our dispute resolution system that
covers those four Specialties so they
all ended up using the federal one
yeah but we don't know to what extent
because we don't have a breakdown for
the federal process by how many per
state
um so assuming that um
yes represent Grayson
thank you Mr chair if if somebody uh has
a complaint and they use the state's
resolution process they're not satisfied
with that can they or is there a
provision that allows them to then use
the federal dispute system or or in
Reverse no so I'll just lay out the two
different systems so the state system is
when the provider and the insurer do not
agree on what a reasonable rate is to be
paid
um they're instructed to try to work it
out if they can't they can petition the
insurance commissioner to have a hearing
on the matter they'll present evidence
and then the insurance commissioner
would ultimately decide what the
reasonable rate is that is binding on
them and the commissioner has exclusive
jurisdiction under the federal process
there's an independent dispute
resolution entity where each side
there's um very specific time limits if
you don't fall within that you're out
but um assuming you do you file
everything each side submits their
number of what they think is the
appropriate rate and then they can
submit evidence about certain factors
and then that independent dispute
resolution entity picks one or the other
and that's done there is no appeal in
the federal system either
thank you
okay so um I'm pretty sure you guys will
have somebody remember obviously
representative Weston won't be here but
I know representative Leno is going to
be running again and he cares he was
very much involved with the balance
billing issue
that was in this one but that that the
issue and he was the Prime sponsor of
the original balance building statute so
I'm sure he cares and he'll put in
legislation I'm sure and at that point
in time I hope you guys will come in to
tell us
what's been going on uh you know in
terms of what's happening in the state
but I mean I I guess part of me feels
like this is if there are very minimal
problems have occurred then that means
our statute was good it it it seemed to
keep everybody happy but
um I I they're part of me that feels
like that if the federal government was
willing to let us run it I I think it's
better for our New Hampshire consumers
to be able to make a call you know here
locally rather than having to rely on a
federal statute so I think there's
something to be said for it but at this
point in time this bill is you know we
need we need more work on this bill
representative
just just so I understand
who has authority over the hospitals is
it the insurance department or is it no
it'd be CMS the federal government
oversees it DHHS does some oversight of
it but a lot of it um falls on CMS as
well so there's depending on what the
issue is I believe it's joint
jurisdiction
but the insurance department has no
Authority with the balanced billing
situations it specifically gives the
commissioner The Authority in these
specific disputes to mediate this law to
resolve the dispute between them but
generally speaking we do not have
authority over them
I do okay so if we're gonna go not
recommend who's gonna make the motion
who you want to you'll take care of that
representative Bartlett
okay
uh Senate Bill 121 relative to
state-based Health Insurance Exchange oh
yeah
now
I remember why you're here
um
so uh you want to remind this is that
we're we are we had chosen to be part of
the federal exchange and uh there's a
company that wants to come in and says
it's going to save us money maybe
on on switching to a steady big exchange
because we know where we will do a
bang-up job with this software and
and what we won't have glitches that
everyone was afraid of if we had a
state-based system
thank you Mr chairman uh Peter Bragdon
representing uh getting short uh briefly
the bill yeah allowed the state to set
up a state-based exchange for the
Affordable Care Act uh the state uh
chose back when it was started to have a
federal exchange for various reasons
um partially due to the fact there was
no very few other options at the time uh
now an industry has evolved where there
are private companies that offer
basically Exchange in a box that have
proven they can save some money so this
Bill said okay the department will
investigate it and if they want to go
ahead and do it this committee had some
concerns which I think are legitimate
concerns that uh needed more information
about the program and a little concerned
about having the department just decide
to do something uh with some other
approval as well so what I think when we
last met uh with the committee uh you
folks had thought maybe the best thing
to do for this is have a study committee
next year
and talk about between now and the bill
filing period what that study committee
should look at so that the committee
down the road then make an informed
decision
about whether this might work or not and
have some data behind it so
um I would uh my inkling was from that
that the committee would probably say
okay this bill is not recommended for
further legislation however a study of
the issue would be warranted
right
they study Commission
committee commission whichever oh yeah
right
oh yeah do you want to join a commission
or you want a study committee let me
talk to you about the difference between
but in this case it wasn't even it was
it was we were delegating the authority
to the to the department and never
actually having them to come back to us
and getting the blessing that the
department could just unilaterally go
ahead and implement it uh if they
thought that they could pull that off
right right and there was some
discussion too about uh where has this
succeeded in other states what has
happened how much does it cost uh all
those things all worthy of a study I
think yeah in my memories it was nothing
nothing was really out of the box they
still had to make change you would still
have to adapt the software for New
Hampshire yeah things would be
customized I do know that since we met
the state of Virginia has switched
customers
okay representative Abrams uh more of a
comment than a question but you're
welcome to respond
um in our platform we say free market
competition in healthcare and more
choice for consumers Max you want to
move the microphone a Little Closer
I'm doing it myself
[Music]
um summarizing the Republican platform
uh giving consumers more choice and
options in order to get costs down but a
big part of that and what I've heard
from a lot of my constituents is they
want to be able to choose their own
doctor they want to choose their own
plan because of quality and because of
the the quality of care and the the type
of service that they get
um
um when I look at these bills
um that's actually first and foremost in
my mind I do think about the cost of
care I think we do think about the cost
of insurance but the the number one
thing that I'm looking at is trying to
improve the quality because that's what
I'm hearing about more for my
constituents
yeah so the uh every Insurance product
sold in the State uh has a surcharge on
it that pays the federal government to
run the federal health exchange and so
the argument is that those states that
have switched to a state-based exchange
using some of the private companies that
compete in this market are able to save
money and thus reduce the tax that
consumers have to pay
but let's answer his question that in
this exchange there is no networks
limiting who your provider can be uh
right this is just a different way to
implement the Affordable Care Act
um and so should you not care for the
Affordable Care Act that's a whole
different story uh and if you like the
Affordable Care Act it's a different
story we're required to have it under
federal law so but it's not like he was
worried about choosing his own doctors
and all right right this really is not
uh it doesn't affect that
representative Ammon
that you're sure just a suggestion for
the study commission duties is uh
consider patient privacy I think there's
a big push in HHS to make sure that
whatever system we put in place doesn't
leak data uh and that privacy is
maintained yeah that would be very
important and if there are folks here
that would like to be a part of that
study or help shape what that bill looks
like uh you might be hearing from me
it looks like I had my name on that bill
didn't I well son of a gun
I believe there were some very highly
esteemed legislators as coasters I don't
remember that we were just giving to the
department and and washing our hands of
it but that's probably something small
that must have happened on the Senate
side okay
I just want to say that if there is a
commission the Democratic plan the
Democrats platform is to work on a
bipartisan basis for the record thank
you
and it looks like Senator Roswell was
the Prime sponsor of the bill
that is true
okay who would like to make the motion
thank you representative Bartlett
okay
that yes she so who she'll make the
motion that not recommend for future
legislation but that you know this you
know that we realize that this
legislation will probably come in again
and that uh it should become in a
different form like a commission
and have privacy issues
how far but how far
half hour ahead
um
so we get
pandas
yeah
okay why don't we take a a brief yeah we
got a brief break for for panda
and see if somebody shows up for that
foreign
thank you
very much
I think it's coming
it's time
experience
see you
Europe
yes
foreign
everybody
okay thanks
guys
foreign
of course I'm I'm Benjamin buttons I'm
getting all younger a lot older
I just remind me this is this is
platinum now I was I was a I was uh you
know Platinum blunt when I was a kid you
know right toe head so this is it
it's
more Platinum
okay
all right so we're close enough we'll
take up uh 1501
a relative insurance coverage for
Pediatric autoimmune
Neuropsychiatric disorders
did she right she must had a call
today that's that was a mistake nobody
wishes to address it
that was a mistake
I I didn't I didn't I
she couldn't read my scribble
it was my fault all right good morning
again
and introduce yourself and
I'm Michelle Heaton I'm the health law
and policy legal counsel at the
insurance department
and so the last we left it was the uh
Department uh struggling because we're
the DSM still does not have recognized
pins and this is still no code
yeah it's a typical disease to track and
diagnose so without clear diagnoses
we're unable it's not something that can
be coded for with building billing so
we're unable to really track it very
well
under this provision the mental health
law
mental health is an ehb essential health
benefit so under ACA it does need to be
covered
um
so we don't think this provision is
really necessary
we understand why we would want to be
looking at this but from an insurance
perspective we don't think it's
necessary to have the Mandate in there
because it would be covered anyways and
it's the type of condition that is
not as definite as we would like okay
so and and as far as you know there have
no complaints or anything coming in
about no it's not something that we get
complaints about in the department okay
so thank you very much sounds like not
recommended for future legislation and
who would like to carry this one forward
oh representative Herbert all right
[Laughter]
okay
um
chiropractors
because I would think there will be a
chiropractor or two who want to show up
for that one
I apologize
you know yeah ouch
need some entertainment
uh
discuss what we're gonna do
they want to be treated like primary
care physicians
um we did have testimony from
chiropractors that are affected
um but Tyler Brennan was here too and
said that
um
right now the chiropractors are sort of
treated like
um it's a specialty well it's a special
day but
the insurance usually covers a certain
number of visits well that makes it
unusual that's from that was my issue my
issue was always that we had
carved out a special mandate for
chiropractory and that is if a carrier
is going to offer
Chiropractic benefits in other words
it's not mandated to have chiropractor
but if they were going to the Mandate
was that you can at least do 12 Billings
a year you can have monthly billing
and
um and and which of course
but the co-pays really Mount up right
but at that time I I was adamantly
opposed to that legislation and because
I thought it was an unfunded mandate and
uh and and
um and I kept saying but by the way guys
uh I won't be surprised if some
insurance company drops chiropractor
coverage and sure enough did not Signet
drop it which in the in the room George
is not in the room but but they actually
did drop the coverage now since then
they've now picked it up but they when
they picked it up the copay is is
yeah it's brutal it's not it's not very
good there are some we also heard
testimony that some are as low as ten
dollars
right
no it's basically now it's just
basically a
sign-in fee and and you know and the
person has to pay out of pocket I mean
the co-pays have changed so much over
the last 20 years used to be two visits
a year you know you had to pay well the
two visits these days are up to what a
visit to the
for just your regular physicals 175 or
something like that and if we had to pay
that twice a year everybody be up in
arms right so when I served on the board
of Healthy Kids one of the things we
were acutely aware of is
um it is the co it's the importance of
the copay deductible and the impact on
getting someone to
get something taken care of right and
that you never want to you you want you
want cost sharing so you want to have
some skin in the game to go to the
doctor but you don't want it to be too
high that they say I'm not going to do
it right because it's too much
and um so you know that's uh right now
you
there are a lot of you're going to your
primary care physician is there some
case you you don't have you have no
copay right okay right
again saying to you you know don't try
to get that specialist don't try to just
come on in come on in and and we'll take
care of you know and get an address or
at least find out get into the system
um
with state employees have Aetna and
they're calling you constantly for a
home visit well I just had my physical
last week or something and they still
want me to have a home visit I don't
want a home visit well yeah that home
visit that actually is is Medicare well
it's a that's a Medicare mandate but the
state and it's so unbelievable when
Harvard called me and said and begged me
to have a talk have someone come to my
house I'm not doing it no no it is
ridiculous but at any rate
um
but I mean the problem with this the
advantage part of the advantage you know
because when I said you know when I was
before but now that I'm on advantage and
they they're calling up and say yeah we
want to come in and and you know take
your blood pressure I'm not gonna do it
now they've got even 100 Amazon gift
card this week right and I said no oh
yeah exactly they wanted to give you a
75 gift card to come come visit you at
your home and then and then this is this
is Advantage if you're in Medicare
Advantage which assume you might know
the difference of regular Medicare right
so
then I then they started having someone
she was calling me every month
and I finally I said both of you and I
finally like you know because I didn't
get really the result because I again I
had a problem with my toes and turns out
like you know that's why I need special
inserts and a lot of us have Orthotics
and uh and I finally says you know are
you guys built I know I pulled out my
Harvard monthly statement and saw that
they were getting billed for that phone
call and I called immediately called
back and I said you turned this thing
off right now I've asked him a few times
to stop calling us and they keep calling
yeah really I didn't know that yes you
have to call you have to tell them okay
you don't talk to the person who's
calling you no because they're just
doing their job you got to call you know
the actual I'll talk to administrative
services
their bill yeah would you get your you
get monthly I mean I don't know who you
have Advantage I have Harvard we have
we're state employees right so you don't
yeah manage but
um so they don't send you a monthly
statement of your oh yeah they emailed
it finally but nobody you know they send
you all these pages and they got foreign
language page and they've got cover
pages and you have to kind of weave
through it to one page and they're in
the middle of the page whereas you know
that yeah they were billing
15 Ballers or something yeah
no it's not mental health but anyway um
to go back to this bill
um I think that
Chiropractic has certainly an important
place in health care yeah I agree but
taking it you know
to reduce the charge for no let's say
those charge for primary care physician
or osteopath
um should not be greater than
12 visits a year
well that was what I said I don't know
if you remember I said if you're willing
to repeal the 12 yeah that's because I
didn't like that in the first place if
you're willing to repeal that then I'm
willing to you know let people get that
coverage because for me every time I you
know I've done something where I pick
you know bad you know got my back
twisted and I I don't call any other
doctor I just go right to my
chiropractor and get the twist right and
and sometimes say yes don't you want to
come back tomorrow or come back you know
no no all I need is one twist and that
and that really is there's always been
you know knock on wood that's always
worked for me yeah um so yeah you know
if it's just that kind of service which
is almost emergency room if you call
that you know to me until coming in and
then so if they're willing to let go of
that 12 12 12 visits a year mandate uh I
would be willing to consider this bill
but Tyler Brennan also told us according
to my notes here that you can expect
premiums to go up to be affected there's
no doubt by um reducing the co-pays and
I want have a tough time with that
I
I'm shocked no you're not
what's high
ER
they would have to make the referral
right right but you're supposed to
you're supposed to go to your primary
first or at least talk to the their
their nurse ahead of time and she'll you
know kind of cover you know
the triage you and sometimes they'll
refer you and sometimes they'll say no
and most of the times they'll tell you
you got to come in most most of the time
these days you got to come in and they
and then and then they'll evaluate it
and then and of course they're they're
trained to send you to you know they're
a surgeon they're well but they're
they're not gonna they don't want you to
send you to fit they won't no no they're
going to send you the surgeon this
surgeon is the one who's gonna refer to
physical therapy they own the physical
therapy please well that was that was
that was we've had that legislation that
goes way back I mean I remember when
George Roberts was the the lobbyist on
that one but yeah
yes
so I sort of
refreshing my memory but I know a lot of
the insurance companies or at least the
one I know I have they have taken off
the limits of the number of Chiropractic
visits you can go as many times as you
want
um
and it's it's worked great and I think a
lot of them because the demand is there
and they can see the benefits from it
right that it's saving them money that I
think that you know I really don't think
this bill is needed and I think that
because the patients are asking for it
it
but this bill would be to reduce the
co-pays
for as many visits as you have
right that's what this bill's about
yeah yeah so she's saying that we don't
need this bill because because they
they're they're actually increased to
12. there you can get as many as you
want but yeah it's you've got your skin
in the game you're going to make that
copay knowing full well that you want
all those visits
but you are going to pay co-pays for
each of them right and it's still
considered a specialty so I don't think
we need I mean in my opinion I don't
think but we should recommend this for
further legislation
so is there anybody in the audience who
wants to lay in on this I I know the
sponsor so I wouldn't be surprised he's
going to show up but
um
Mr chairman this bill refresh my
memories just to reduce the co-payments
correct well basically is to match
whatever your policy has for Primary
Care primary care physician so basically
this is this is a request to increase
overall premiums it will absolutely
increase premiums right and this issue
this this bill did not deal with whether
you needed to be referred by a primary
had nothing to do with any of that
refers that that is an issue
a primary care physician won't refer you
to a country right as you as you
mentioned because one serious issue is
that there are people who find that it's
a healthful practice
for them to see a chiropractor but they
can't continue to go and receive
coverage unless it they can document an
injury right so unless you're injured
you can't you can't receive an insurance
benefit that's another issue that's not
covered in this bill okay we'll take
that up some other year maybe okay thank
you
yes maximum
oh yeah representative petusic
thank you thank you Mr chairman uh I go
to a chiropractor every month you know
12 visits and I know their fee schedule
because I am on Medicare and I have
United Healthcare as my secondary their
fee schedule is different for me than it
is for a walk-in that this is not on
Medicare
so they do have different fee schedules
depending on probably their insurer and
some do have more lenient and summer
very tight so I just thought I'd share
that thank you Mr chairman I directed
question to representative yeah
absolutely yeah we have a question so so
you you have 12
yes do you have to document an injury
so with your insurance you get 12 for no
reason whatsoever other than your own
health because he's Medicare Medicare
too but I have to document an injury so
okay thank you yeah and who's your
supplemental
anthem
I go first first Monday of every month
like clockwork
they might want to look you might want
to teach yourself
so I and I would let's just say just a
second is that if I'm I would say is
that this legislation would only affect
it's no small group Market it would not
affect Medicare so that all of us in the
room would not be affected by this
Legacy anyway
he said Max Max
okay yes representative
um so it's just a comment but I'm I I
kind of feel at this point that I'm
leaning against it my reason is that I
view Insurance like
car insurance Life Insurance homeowners
insurance it's it's just something to
deal with the you know occasional
unexpected big out of control costs that
it's it's
sorry about that I'm doing it myself
again
it it it's not efficient to pay an
insurance company as a third party to
pay for a routine expected visits I do
I've used chiropractors many many times
and I've always paid cash it's it's
unless my insurance covered it
um but insurance is cheaper if it's only
covering you know something five
thousand ten thousand dollar or thirty
thousand dollars something that's a big
unexpected cost I know that there are a
lot of people who want to have an
insurance plan where they just show
their card like back in the 50s and 60s
and you just showed your card and
somebody else took care of it but that's
had the tendency to encourage costs to
go up and up and up it doesn't have the
Cost Containment and you know it's like
it's like the Free bottle of Tylenol
people would just kind of go into the
office and grab the Free bottle of
Tylenol as soon as they put a one dollar
copay on it people don't grab as much
but I wouldn't expect to pay for routine
expenses like an oil change through my
car insurance I wouldn't expect to pay
for replacing a roof or Landscaping
through my homeowner's policy
representative pilot so I I um
representative just wanted to tell you
in the 50s and 60s we did pay for the
first two office visits each year
yeah just to let you know right and the
office visits of course have gone up
tremendously and co-pays came in and
that kind of thing but but you're
absolutely right the insurance was there
for the sudden unexpected and you um
planned for the lower costs
I might yeah so they back in the 30s and
40s and 50s
um they used to sell life insurance
plans correct that would just have a
health insurance plan attached to it as
a little free vending but it was always
80 20. yeah it was 80 20. it was the
insurance company would cover the 80 you
always had to pay 20 but it was health
insurance was five percent of GDP just
like it is in Hong Kong or Singapore
today it was it was there was very
little government involvement there were
very few of these Insurance mandates
like this bill so we had you know you
had a much more affordable system so
therefore in some parts of the country
didn't even yeah I mean absolutely I
remember in the 70s when that but I was
in college and had to be educated on on
this and um most employers is the
employers
insurance it was a life a ten thousand
dollar life insurance policy that also
happened to have
the health insurance benefit 80 20. and
and when people ask me well what changed
between now and then I would say number
one is Pharmaceutical
number one drugs you know back then we
didn't have all these wonderful new
invented drugs you know we had aspirin
and uh you know so now we had the
A and B is the Specialties that that we
didn't have all those doctors who were
special Specialties that got referred to
and that's the reason why health
insurance premiums have gone through the
roof
we could blame hospitals because Paul
left
yes representative well I just wonder
how is this going to impact people like
with chronic back pain you know that's
not an emergency and for a lot of people
they do get relief
um and you know to me it's like a
toothache you know you have a really bad
toothache you really can't function and
back back pain is is can also really
deter you from doing the things you do
in your life particularly if you have an
active job so you know how is that going
to impact those folks
well right now how is it impacting
because right now the current law is
that you know that that the copay is uh
is relatively high as compared to what
you would pay for your primary yeah so
you know so saying that might help I
mean you know again nobody goes to the
primary every month for something
that's the point that was the point of
this bill is that that the difference is
it's a different kind of service
so if it if it was anything it should be
well what's the copay for your physical
therapist if you're going to see them
every month
uh not primary care that was the problem
with this bill is this bill was
associated with primary care physician
okay we're getting close to see if
somebody shows up but uh who who would
be the one willing to carry this forward
[Music]
representative Bartlett thank you for
okay
and it's lunchtime
yeah so let's just we'll wait till 11 30
and see if anybody shows up and
otherwise we'll break for lunch
oh uh Mr chair yes um I did have a a
question on the panda bill
um okay so I guess it's kind of a
lingering question but what the estimate
of I think I asked it during the
previous executive session with the
estimate of the increase cost would be
just passed it so right now um the
problem with pandas is we we actually
don't know if it exists what's the
extent or what's going on out there
because it doesn't have a billing code
it's a very unusual circumstance and and
uh one of the things I learned on this
committee
um years ago is about the DSM are you
familiar with the DSM
um what was that what is the DSM someone
help me out with
yeah diagnostic
uh but it's for mental health to mental
health and I think we're up to like nine
now when I first got on this committee
we were at four so they have improved
and and just to show you how
controversial it potentially was that
way back in four
um I think they actually uh said uh
being gay was actually a mental health
condition
so it has gone through its own
progressions over the years
um in terms of what is in the DSM but
the DSM is the Bible of diagnosing
um mental illness and pandas is not in
in there it doesn't it has not been
picked up
so in our in our cases what what we
learned with the insurance companies the
department was that
um it is covered but it's covered under
a different diagnosis
and so therefore is to really identify
pandas and making sure it's being
covered as a panda is we it's hard to
mandate something that doesn't hasn't
it's not in the DSM
but having said that that we we never
heard that the people weren't getting
coverage well the original testimony was
a guy who had a daughter
it was even more than that it was back
when Macbeth or sonic actually she was
on the committee she was she was a
member of the committee when way back
yeah
right
thank you
right right
I remember that
right
really
expressions
like yeah I remember that
right
um and when we when we got you know
really into the Weeds on it
we came up with a bill that said you
know they've they need the we had the
department told the department to pay
attention
see what was going on right and then two
years later you know Tyler came back and
said well we can't really code it we
don't really know but there had not been
work but he did have some other code
that he thought was the one that was
being used so I remember I don't think
it was very specific though no it wasn't
specific but it wasn't specific the
pandas for sure but he said he said this
is the one the closest one that they
think is is being used if it's being
used you know out there but I think I
mean the bottom line is we have not
heard the insurance department has not
heard more complaints and we have not
had more constituents coming in and
saying their child needs the coverage
and right they're not getting coverage
right um
so
okay I agree represent Grayson thank you
quicker what uh what type of doctor or
what specialist uh would treat
a patient with pandas
I was doing a psychiatrist but I don't
know do you know you remember Paula
yes sir
hi Paula Rogers this was had a long
history and it was a fraught with a lot
of sort of emotional testimony and
basically the mandate
was put into place the issue was not so
much that a child with this the the
um
child diagnosed as having possibly
having pandas which is associated with
neurological developments that occur
subsequent to or along with a
streptococcal infection
and there was a lot of
testimony and a lot of Confusion And if
you go online and I did that last night
because it sort of interested me what is
the recent
what's the recent take on pandas because
the there were a number of states that
immediately passed mandates but there
were not that many
the issue was child presents with
symptoms it probably goes to a
pediatrician in the first instance the
Pediatric folks had taken a position
that certain medications were probably
not appropriate for treatment if this
diagnosis was presented and the most
controversial were to something called
aphoresis and another which was IVIG
which is immunoglobulin both infusions
very expensive with lots of side effects
and a lot of concern among the Pediatric
population of Physicians
what should we do here and so it went
back and forth and the issues seemed to
really come right down to the IVIG which
is an immunoglobulin infusion which is
given to apparently kids who have
serious indications of pandas
and many of the carries were concerned
about this I think we gently objected to
it it was put on the books and the issue
was thought to be well let's see what
happens so for three years four years
it's been on the books I don't think
Anthem and Sabrina Dunlop is here and
she would be more current of that has
had any complaints about that
so IVIG has been provided I would
suspect that a lot of Physicians aren't
prescribing it because it was kind of
iffy as a treatment so that's kind of
where we are with this nobody is
debating that there isn't this syndrome
but the treatment around it is clearly
very problematic and when I looked at
recent issues last night as best as I
could by Googling about it doesn't seem
that there's anything more definitive
but I mean psychiatric component but
we're talking hundreds of thousands of
dollars per year for treatment yes I
think an infusion could be as much as
fifteen thousand dollars right and they
would a child might have five or six of
those infusions and this is a chronic
condition this is this is something that
we had testimony that one had occurred
at seven years old but one had been
going on at like 14 and had gone into
this his 20s he'd been in and out of
jail because it's a behavioral
the symptomatic the symptoms are
behavioral which cause real
social problems and a real question as
to the is this really Associated right
really I mean it's a really hard
condition and it's rare so there have
been no compliance so I'm not so sure
why you would want to keep the
thing going and what the traditional
thing would be you know
um probably
some sort of steroid
for any inflammation antibiotics maybe
Psychotherapy for the child but we heard
about terribly terribly severe cases
really did
um
so it was it was very emotional but
right now we still it's still
the Mandate is that it would still be on
the books until uh July 1st of 2024 I
believe so there'd still be more time if
more evidence came out and and really as
a committee none of us are doctors we
we don't know even with a testimony of
doctors and insurance carriers and
attorneys we don't know if this
treatment is actually effective
but your heart goes out to the families
that have had to deal with this there's
you know and like you were saying some
of it is and even anecdotal because
they're still trying to figure out
what the cause is put the committee in
an odd position of trying to come up
with a clinical
basis for passing a statutory provision
and I'm sure chairman remembers the one
with uh breast cancer and
and you know what forgotten exactly what
it was well it was meant it was meant a
um
bone marrow transplants for her but it
was it was for solid cancers it was no
situation
yeah and that was on the books and we
finally got that off the books and that
was a struggle it took many years to get
it get it off and I don't think it was
utilized it was in conjunction with
researcher at Dartmouth that was it was
in Lebanon they were doing it so it puts
the it puts you in an artist position
it's hard to not want to do something
okay uh representative Ammon
representative Bartlett made my point
that if we do nothing we still have all
next term to uh deal with the
termination date of July 1st 2024. but
the study the monitoring of it by the
insurance department and they're
supposed to annual give us an annual
reporters on on
what they learn of what's Happening
that's yeah that's what the original
Bill had required
um and this bill was just too I I think
it was true just to force out the the
four it pushed the effective date yeah
Sunset yeah to repeal the sunsets right
right right so
okay uh Last Chance anybody want to talk
about uh chiropractors
yes representative Emerson oh I just
wanted to make a point on both on this
bill and the other bill
um I think four or five years ago I put
in a bill on health savings accounts and
one of the I think is for HHS one of the
arguments that I made or the case that I
made for
um that qualifying High deductible plan
was uh that with health savings accounts
money builds up over time and you're
always going to have something that that
isn't covered or something that's a
brand new type of treatment or
experimental treatment of some kind and
health savings accounts you can you can
pay for things because you have over
time you build up a couple hundred
thousand dollars in that per person and
you can cover things that are unusual or
unexpected that the insurance might not
cover and it gives you a lot more
flexibility you can take that card
anywhere in the world if you want
okay we'll break for lunch
foreign
thank you
okay why don't we get started in here
old moment
we're talking about the caller
okay
now let's do it before Max gets back
let's do this one before Max gets back
actually
you know you know I don't ever regret
anything I've ever said or done
no life you have life yeah but okay
HP 488 establishing committee to study
the benefits of allowing New Hampshire
citizens to purchase health insurance
from out of state companies
and
Jeffy are you sponsored this
okay I didn't okay so as I I'll say what
I've said a million times if there was
some out-of-state insurance company that
wants to sell health insurance New
Hampshire citizens I'd be the first one
to sponsor that bill but I need to I
need to have that company
come to me and say they want to do it
I'll uh make the motion that let's not
be recommended for okay uh future
legislation
you know through Medicare or
supplemental is uh Martin's Point and
they're out of me oh there are yeah
they're yes and I that's right is that
different because it's yes so this is
this is about uh the small group Market
so this would be employer based product
or in in the individual Market but
um what happens is companies license
themselves in the state because the
state is the regulator
of the policy okay so there's no
regulation if it's out of state so
and if you if you wanted the long story
and I'll try to do it in 60 seconds in
the old days prior to the Affordable
Care Act
and let's say even prior to when we had
7-Eleven which Paul and I are the only
ones in the room were around for that
nightmare but uh so when we passed you
know Gene chaheen's you know the act the
issue was that uh insurance companies
would medically underwrite all the
employees
and um sure enough one of the reasons
why I actually voted for it so
much of this your grin I guess but
probably is that I I voted for the
Affordable Care Act long before anybody
called it that because my company which
I had to come you know 20 employees we
were Matthew Thornton which is a
non-profit you know eventually get
absorbed by Anthony that they uh two
months after we had a renewal we got we
got dropped
and uh what do you mean you can't drop
us we just signed the paper you know
we're all outside of it I don't know we
have we have the right you don't see
down somewhere in the fine print that we
have the right to drop you and and the
reason they dropped us was because we
had an employee whose son
uh got hurt on a three-wheeler remember
the three wheelers the front wheel in
the front and the two and and and he got
really mangled and so one of the guys
with the bean counters the medical
Underwriters said he decided our group
which was we were selling in computers
so we were generally young people and so
they decided that they just they didn't
want us to be on their plan anymore so
they just
drop this so medical underwriting was
clearly a big issue and so when you look
at as we move the clock forward going
forward what what happens is that
yes New Hampshire did pass 7-Eleven and
we did narrow how many insurance
companies were selling health insurance
in the state and uh and you say well my
cousin you know I talked to him he's
down in Arizona and there his insurance
is half my premium well why well because
other states had medical underwriting
and so therefore if you had a good
healthy group you got cheap insurance
whereas New Hampshire we were obviously
you know under the Affordable Care Act
before it was for a care act so this
concept of buying health insurance
across state lines really States back to
the old days when States really did have
variable rates and that you know that
some states were clearly you know you'd
be cheap Assurance but as the the
running rule the running joke was but
don't ever make a claim
because you start making a claim then
bam they'll send you that discontinued
nose
um so yes it would be I if some
out-of-state company wants to come into
New Hampshire and sell health insurance
in New Hampshire and say that you're now
regulated by the laws of that state
not this state right well you know guess
what well
another issue now now I'm going to spend
another minute another issue we had not
dealt with much in this committee is the
consumer protection act except that bill
yesterday okay well as the defender of
the consumer protection act one of the
big things was is the is that I was able
to mandate the insurance commissioner
have power restitution for the consumer
and in that there are the exemptions is
that insurance companies are not under
the consumer protection act because
they're regulated by the insurance
department so if you're an out-of-state
insurance company selling a product in
New Hampshire
you would not get that exception
you would follow the fault you would end
up under our consumer protection act
which has the right of private action
and triple damages so I can assure you
and this is how Bill O'Brien when I
explain this to Bill O'Brien in a
heartbeat he knew exactly what I was
talking about and he said he said okay I
get it no insurance company is going to
want to come into this state and not be
regulated by the insurance commissioner
because then anybody could sue them for
triple damages if they were not happy
with the insurance product they were
getting so this is a concept that is uh
had some truth to it
it is never going to make you know never
no company's ever going to do it but I
would always go on record and say
if some insurance company comes to me
and say yeah we want to sell it in New
Hampshire Market
uh fine with me I'll write the
legislation for you I'll make sure I'll
streamline it all in but it ain't gonna
ever happen
represent back later just to take it a
step further I don't think they can do
that in other words I think the
insurance statutes say in order for you
to sell a policy in New Hampshire like
any other state that insurance company
has to be doesn't have to be domiciled
in New Hampshire but it has to be
licensed exact temperature and if you're
not in lace in New Hampshire you simply
can't sell I would have so if they
really wanted to to bypass that statute
I don't think they can I no that we we
would I would be the first one to write
that bill to allow them to do that all
right you know what I'm saying that I
yeah no I'm I'm I'm pro-choice I I if
they want to come in and do that I I
would certainly enable them to do it but
I I have no illusions that any of them
will ever when I choose that and and
like you say you get to the real heart
of the issue is the domicile you know if
they are domicile in their own state
so representative Abramson so I
so this is uh two issues on the
philosophical or legal legislative issue
the question is
do we change the law to allow it to
happen before someone comes in or do we
wait until someone presumably with a
paid lobbyist comes in and and asks to
have the law be changed and I've always
said
make it legal first make it allowable
first and then someone will come in and
come to the insurance department the
second thing is the staying on the topic
of the bill the bill is is only asking
uh to establish a committee to study the
benefits and we had several years ago
when a similar bill came in
um we wanted to figure out under
Governor Hassan we wanted to figure out
what the actual potential savings would
be and the insurance commissioner at
that time first said 10 savings and then
he said five percent savings and he said
possibly as low as three percent savings
on health insurance costs and I came
back to some of the then members of this
committee and I said again just what I
said before it isn't just the savings
we're talking about all the benefits
including improved Choice improved
quality of care when you have the right
to go somewhere else companies tend to
want to compete for you not just on cost
but on service on having better tech
support having somebody available 24 7
having out of network services and so on
whatever it is that the consumer wants
so I I think that just
it um I'm not sure that the bill even
necessarily advocates for it but it was
just the question was asking first and
foremost before we try to make a
decision on that what are the benefits
um is there a cost savings and even if
the cost savings is minimal could there
be an improvement in quality of life or
reduction in infant mortality rates or
hospital infection rates or what have
you we'd have to really do a deep dive
in that and that would require a group
to look into that
fair enough
any other discussion anybody want to
carry this for representative Bartlett
okay so representative Barton moves that
not
sure come on up
again Michelle Heaton from the New
Hampshire insurance department
um just to clarify under our current
statutes if you want to do business of
insurance in the commercial Market in
New Hampshire you do have to be licensed
that doesn't necessarily mean your
domiciled here we have a number of
insurance companies that are domiciled
in other states but they have to be
licensed in New Hampshire to do business
in New Hampshire so that's one part of
it the second part of it is that we
require
forms and rates to be filed with our
department for review to make sure
they're meeting all of the requirements
of New Hampshire law before they can be
sold here
so if we were to allow
someone who was not licensed in New
Hampshire to sell insurance products in
New Hampshire essentially we would be
taking away any regulation of that so
they would have be able to sell products
that the New Hampshire insurance
department would not be regulating that
those could be products that do not meet
any of our consumer protections none of
especially for major Med none of our
mandates and then if there's a problem
with it New Hampshire insurance
department wouldn't have any
jurisdiction to try to resolve that
issue or we wouldn't have any
jurisdiction over the insurance company
that's doing this unless they are
licensed in New Hampshire
so that's just to clarify some of those
points representative aberson
I feel like I asked this question a few
years ago
um
and the
so we have so we have some people in
some companies and some small business
quite a few small businesses that can't
afford a regular you know full-on
private insurance plan
um my thought was and another reason
that I wanted this study committee to go
forward was
could it be possible that you have say
an insurance company that does operate
in New Hampshire follows the 44
different Insurance mandates and and all
the regulations would they be able if
they have customers who can no longer
and forward the increases could they
partner with say an out-of-state
insurance company or HMO or set up an
out-of-state insurance company or HMO to
offer a low-cost plan so that they don't
lose those people
in other words
um
I I feel like what they were trying to
do with with Obamacare in the exchange
was if people couldn't get a regular
full-blown
You Know cover everything private
insurance policy that the exchange was
kind of trying to at least initially
offer some low-cost options and maybe
even out-of-state insurance or buy
something on the exchange that would be
a lower cost option for people couldn't
afford a regular plan so all the plans
on the exchange sold in New Hampshire
are New Hampshire approved plans that
have gone through the process so I don't
think that you're going to be able to
realize that cost savings by going and
getting a plan that's offered in another
state because every state has its own
set of mandates and requirements so if
you look at the cost of insurance
Nationwide New Hampshire is typically on
the lower end of that
are you actually listening to what she's
saying yes and but I haven't I have a
follow-up it's somewhat unrelated
but we just told you you're asking is I
I have this fantasy that there is a
health insurance light program out there
that doesn't have the mandates that
doesn't have all that stuff and it's
going to be cheaper
and it's in another state somewhere
why are you labeling that a fantasy
because it's a fantasy
there is no that in the old days that
was true when everybody had when some
states had medical underwriting that's
where the savings was but in terms of
mandates yes it is true I think I did
hear that we have more mandates than
most States and I guess I have to take
responsibility because I've been here
when most of those mandates passed okay
but mandates are only about five percent
of the premium so the end of the day the
real saving
if you ever thought that there was
another insurance plan out there hiding
on in some state
the real savings was under medical
underwriting in which no state has that
anymore
so if I could ask the witness a
follow-up sure
so
uh the people in my town in Seabrook
they can choose Portsmouth they can
choose Exeter they can choose Anna Jakes
which is in Massachusetts
I think about half or maybe even 55
according to the fire department
choose to get taken Anna Jakes when they
have the choice these are hospitals in
my understanding okay since I'm On the
Border
and again when I talk to people about
their doctor their doctor's office the
clinics they go to about half or maybe
even slightly more than half go down
into Massachusetts so there are
Massachusetts insurance plans
If people could buy health insurance
across state lines
wouldn't wouldn't people even who happen
to have a residence or happen to have a
domicile here in New Hampshire be able
to buy into say an HMO in another
neighboring state
or a private insurance plan that's set
up in another state where their Network
their preferred provider network is
primarily in that other state where
they're spending most of their health
care dollars
that's a little bit of a different issue
there could be plans in New Hampshire
sold in New Hampshire approved by New
Hampshire that include broader networks
that would include all of those same
networks in Massachusetts but that is a
different issue than you know making
sure that the insurance company is
licensed so there's
there's a lot of different parts to the
insurance plan and I understand what
you're saying about trying to get you
know cost savings but this particular
bill here of allowing people to buy out
of state plans just removes all of those
consumer protections and the
Department's ability to regulate the
product so that is our concern but in
theory you know there's no prohibitions
about a New Hampshire licensed company
selling a plan that has a broad Network
that would include all of those same
providers in Massachusetts
and oftentimes plans do have to include
providers that are on those borders
because
that's where the care is to meet Network
adequacy requirements
and then there's the ppos and hmos and
that's a whole other question too so
I'll just leave it at that thank you
very much Michelle
representative mclayer do you want to
yes I just want to give an example when
I moved up from Massachusetts I had this
uh very inexpensive Tufts HMO and I mean
the one that they went out of business
I don't know about that but don't cut to
New Hampshire I said she said this is
great I'm going to try to keep this I
couldn't because that plan was not
approved in New Hampshire and anybody
from Seabrook can go to Anna Jake's
Hospital in their New Hampshire
insurance policy will pay Anna Jakes but
you it's the whole thing is mute unless
that insurance company
is licensed in New Hampshire you can't
buy that out of state product you simply
can't it's going to be it doesn't be
again she said it doesn't have to be
domiciled in New Hampshire but has to be
licensed in New Hampshire and and uh
basically uh controlled by New Hampshire
as far as rates go and ability to pay
and all that but what you're looking for
is an absolute oxymoron it does not
exist
okay
any more discussion all right
representative Bartlett will make a
right motion uh not recommended for
future legislation all right next up uh
1162 really uh requiring insurance
coverage for vaccination devices and
medication authorized for America I
think we missed 10 28. oh I'm sorry
I just keep writing your name here
okay 10 20 related to the form of
individual health insurance policies
it's got to be a department bill because
that is that's
this is the one with the um
oh this is yeah okay yeah so that's
right that's right
so um this was an attempt to uh get more
products into the individual Market by
removing coverage
the short-term products yeah so the
short-term products are kind of an
interesting story in this committee
we've had we've dealt with them over the
years
um because they were really they were
originally created for a lapse that if
you're if you changed your employer and
um you you don't have another employer
yet you have a interim period that you
certainly were eligible to COBRA under
the cover law which is the three years
you could stay on your employers your
former employers policy three years but
you had to pay both the employee and the
employer portion of it which would you
know be thousands of thousand dollars a
month and nobody could afford that so
the short-term policies
um were allowed and
and they're
they're a very stripped down they
usually have a limits to how much you
can cover which is some of them I
remember like ten thousand dollars it
was a very limited plan it was a very
stripped Down plan
um so
um it was always it an anathema to the
Affordable Care Act because it didn't
really fit in it really violated the
other functions of the uh of the statute
in terms of what you're required and the
coverages
um so but that they existed simply I
mean I remember one they were used to
you could get them in high schools high
schools used to sell for 100 bucks or
ten bucks or something that you could
get this life insurance plan but it was
only like a thousand dollars and it
wasn't much coverage so but these were
these this short term that I in my
understanding if we're still selling
them in New Hampshire I assume they're
still out there
yeah one company okay but it's just a
lapse just to cover that short period
until you find another employer well
also it's very restricted coverage you
know Mental Health Coverage it's a very
limited benefits
um yeah it's part of the reason why it's
so very much right so I would have to
say this is very creative to come in
with a bill like this because it's
basically saying is let's pass something
that will totally trample on the
Affordable Care Act because all the
limitations all the requirements that
let's just go bypass it but uh it's a
nice idea but that
not gonna work
so anybody want to speak towards this
bill or otherwise represent a Bartlett's
going to make a motion to make it not
recommended for future legislation
yes representative as usual it's an
option it it again we don't
whether something should be legal or
illegal even if no one in the whole
state uses it or buys it or what have
you
it should either be up to the individual
or if something is physically impossible
some of these ideas that people put
forward are probably not possible but
that doesn't mean that the state comes
on and says we're not going to let you
send a rocket up or try to launch the
first airplane because we think that
it's impossible just if the laws of
physics are going to stop something from
happening we let the laws of physics
stop this is not about laws of physics
this is about
we make the laws
okay we decide what's legal
and so
if you're saying we should pass feel
good legislation just because we can
save people we passed it we put this on
our books so that somebody could take
advantage of it
but that when it comes down to it's
never going to be used because
it
it the implementation or what to do
there's nobody out there who wants to do
or offer to do it
it's the sky's the limit just this just
pass all kinds of stuff but at some
point isn't our responsibility to limit
the amount of stuff we put in our books
that we should only pass things that are
are viable we shouldn't limit the
products that are available in the
marketplace but it's not available buyer
but it's not available
we so what I'm saying is what should the
government do what should the state do
my answer is the state should never
restrict anything
uh when it's just one individual buying
a product from someone else
there's one individual buying insurance
or a policy from someone else even if we
don't agree that it's a good idea or
it's not good enough for you or even if
it's not offered we don't duplicate
federal law we don't duplicate the laws
of physics if lawsuit physics are going
to prevent it from happening we don't
need an extra restriction
representative Ammon
yeah I I think representative everson's
reference to the laws of physics has to
do with Innovation right like the
airplane was just an example of
something new that people may be
skeptical of
um this bill is to strike language it's
not to add anything that's true right
um but it does give us a
an opportunity to look at
you know these many arbitrary limits and
deadlines and you know numbers that
somebody put into law
Commerce statues are full of them right
so you know should we make it nine
months instead of six months you know is
there something we can do I think
there's a rollover isn't there a six
month rollover
if you had the six months and then our
roll over the six months
because the statute says just six months
right yeah it says six months um yeah
you know if there is an opportunity for
future legislation it's an opportunity
to look at these seemingly arbitrary
cutoffs and maybe adjust them to fit
reality better
yeah but you have to remember this is
flies in the face of what are but the
products that are available licensed
products in the state
okay that's we should we would have and
actually we got we got burnt a little
bit with that religious exemption we had
that we created this religious plan and
sure enough that company you know did
they
you know we we bend over backwards to
help them out you know to allow them to
be legal but it turns out that they they
couldn't cover the cup make the cover of
the people that was Christian neutral so
that's how that's sort of
representative's uh analogy to laws of
physics right they couldn't do it well
so they didn't well they could have but
they just they I mean I guess
financially they just weren't Smart in
terms of you know that they could have
said to some people we're going to limit
the benefits or they're gonna they
should have the premiums weren't high
enough I think is really problems so
let's talk about cases the six months is
it the Nixon why is it six months why is
it six months because we we want them to
buy a regular licensed product because
that's the that's health and that's
adequate health insurance I mean you
know we used to say it wasn't just
unaffordable it was underinsured the
expression of underinsured that you
think you have an insurance product
right but then you realize when you go
make the claim
it doesn't cover anything it's not it's
it's too skimpy so you were under
insured you didn't have enough shirts
that you thought you so we don't want
anybody to have the illusion that
they're buying a a a viable Insurance
product so if they're under No Illusion
it's better to have limited Insurance
than no insurance right so right that's
that's the consumer protection quote
unquote consumer protection we're not
going to allow you to buy something
that's not you're we potentially you
won't know won't work so you could say
is well can we have some kind of
disclosure that the person fully
understands but next month's here they
they
or banned from having this option at all
and they could be uninsured completely
right uh we would hope that in the six
months they would got themselves into
their highly subsidized individual
Marketplace that under our that we
created I mean if you're unemployed you
can buy into the marketplace for you
know like 25 a month I mean it's it's
dirt cheap I mean there is there are
actually better Alternatives so please
don't avoid it
you know that that this was a leftover
from the the old days that it was a
short-term policy and like you say we
have one company but I bet you they
don't even have a thousand lives I don't
think they have many I'm not sure that
we have numbers on how many lives they
cover but it is one company and just
clarify the policy itself is at Max six
months right but it can be renewed up
into the for coverage for no more than
540 days and like you said the idea is
if someone doesn't have insurance and
there's no open enrollment enrollment
period and they don't qualify for a
special enrollment period which if you
lose a job you lose coverage that would
qualify you for a special enrollment
period where you can buy regular major
Med coverage but if you fall outside of
this these types of policies are
considered kind of like a stop Gap
however even if we got rid of our
restrictions on these plans federal law
dictates how long these can go so
there's still federal law that would
limit the applicability of these and
these plans do not comply AI with all of
the ACA requirements there's a lot of
pre-existing pre-existing condition
exclusions it's not guaranteed renewable
so it is not and a replacement for major
Med also there's the argument that if we
were to allow these notwithstanding
federal law if we were allow people to
purchase these regularly it's taking the
healthier people out of the individual
insurance market and then that could
affect rates over time as well
so that's sort of like socialism works
when everybody is part of it right
that's sort of the argument uh well I
guess the only expression is Insurance
works best if we can get everybody to
buy into it
in other words you don't that you the
more people who buy in Insurance than
the lower the premium is so yeah because
you're spreading the risk but you can't
let people do something different
well you could do something different
it's called don't buy any insurance now
which that it what we're saying is and
here's the good that if don't be
uh don't have the illusion that because
you've got this product you really have
insurance you don't this is not
insurance this is a feel-good idea that
you have some kind of catastrophic
policy but at the end of the day you are
going to be if you ever to make a claim
you're going to be extremely
disappointed and come back to us and say
why the hell did you let let me buy that
okay so make it illegal completely right
we could have we could we could have
done that all right we could have done
that and then technically that's what
the Affordable Care Act did is made
these plans illegal but then we went
back and revised them and said let's
give them some short let's give him some
life because there are consumers in New
Hampshire who just want to have this as
a stop Gap measure
representative Abramson
so
I want to give you an example we had
some left-wing activists come in
and they were holding signs for the
minimum wage and I talked to some of
them and they said that they wanted a 33
an hour minimum wage plus full medical
plus full benefits and so I asked
what do you do to all the people who
currently can't earn 33 dollars an hour
plus you know the full benefits package
and they didn't have an answer and I
said so are you saying you want to ban
all everything that's below your
standard
there's more than half the people in my
town in Seabrook make less than 33
dollars an hour so you're going to be
putting more than half the people in my
town out of work with your proposal if
you continuously say we're going to ban
every option between zero and whatever
we want then everyone who's currently
stuck
you know working for unskilled less
skilled partially retired coming right
out of college whatever coming right out
of high school all of those options are
taken away you're only leaving behind
All or Nothing instead of letting people
get a basic entry-level plan people have
to kind of start somewhere and start
getting
um establish you put if you push the
Bottom Rung of the economic ladder too
high people can't get anything and 30
million Americans have nothing they have
absolutely nothing and then another 20
some odd million have Medicaid and
everyone I've talked to who's on
Medicaid said that that's sometimes
worse than nothing so let me ask you is
it better off what you're asking is just
have a policy out there
that has the absolute right that as soon
as you make one claim
they can cancel the policy
and you're saying is it's better off for
us to offer that option to allow people
to buy that product
knowing full well that as soon as they
make a claim they'll get canceled
then just going with representative
images root says is we should just ban
them all together
we shouldn't we shouldn't let them to be
available
that otherwise the right thing to do is
we should have just stuck to our guns
which is we have made a decision in New
Hampshire that nobody should lose their
policy
simply because they made a claim
we think that is consumer product we
think it's fraudulent to sell a product
that as soon as you make the claim they
cancel you and you don't have it anymore
so we should just repeal this whole
statute altogether 30 million Americans
the result of they have no insurance the
30 million you're talking about are the
people who have no insurance you get to
your first claim
and you get nothing
that's true those 30 million people have
they they have a claim they got to pay
for it out of pocket but they got to
save all that money
that they didn't waste on powering
something
that was fraudulent but what I'm saying
is for those people they before you came
along they get two options you come
along you take away one of those options
you didn't give them anything by Banning
an option that doesn't meet your
approval I'm saying that's not even an
I'm saying that's not even a great
insurance plan it's arguably not even a
health insurance plan that's a one-time
payout it's a one-time thing it's like
life insurance
Yeah well yeah you only get paid out one
time with life insurance hopefully
however
that's it some people you got it you got
it some people have gotten it that's
what it is that's what it was that if
users you make a claim ban okay so
that's not a great plan well should we
make those legal should those be legal
in New Hampshire as an individual if you
choose knowingly to buy that plan
that's up to you but how do we how do we
make sure so we have to and have this
informed consent by the way this is a
One-Shot plan that if you want this plan
you have to understand that you only get
to have one claim
so you're saying that's how we make them
that's all that's available to them at
that price point that they can afford if
they can only get the low-cost option if
someone can only afford a used car we
don't ban used cars we don't have a I
didn't support the Cash for Clunkers
thing where they got rid of lots of used
cars okay so
this particular legislation as it's
written
not recommended for future legislation
but representative Ammon who's now been
inspired by how how do we allow people
to buy a plan that will expire as soon
as they make a claim
and as long as they know ahead of time
as long as they know I mean we're
expiring it for them after 540 days
whether they make a claim or not we're
telling you they need to find something
else yeah they're telling them they
might have paid money in all that time
and never made it yeah that's true
that's what that's that's why people
hate insurance pay for years and I never
make a claim that's right correct it's a
huge racket but you know why we have
cheap you know uh you know Property and
Casualty and auto insurance in the state
is because none of us make claims
so the prime sponsor is currently under
uh
some uh pretty severe cancer I know
that's true that's right so I'll reach I
need to call him anyway yeah I'll I'll
bounce uh ideas off for next time and
we'll see perfect yeah okay no I I yeah
yeah okay I forgot about that okay but
actually this is actually a wonderful
conversation because I think it really
helps everyone here to understand what
health insurance in this state and
really across the country what it really
is all about and where how we got to
where we are so I I do not take anything
away from this conversation
okay now
uh representative Grayson
you're on
yes not 1162. 1162 no no that's right
this is 1162. so this one did we ever
have a problem then Insurance any
insurance company did not cover a
vaccine you're a co-sponsor did anybody
ever hear that this 1162 really was a
problem
no
I mean the vaccines if we're talking
about coveted vaccines they're basically
free right yeah it's all free
so this is
yeah it's 11 62. so the concern was that
uh if somebody were to receive a vaccine
uh primarily of concern or the coveted
vaccines which are not FDA approved no
one absolutely no one has ever gotten an
FDA approved coveted vaccine it is not
on the market and never has been and
never will be on the market right that's
not conjecture that's a fact
so you have received an experimental
drug
and insurance companies are not required
to cover any claims
based on you having taken an
experimental drug
and so the concern was somebody would
get a coveted vaccine would get injured
by that which we know that never happens
and then they would file a claim that
would be denied they wouldn't get
coverage as it appears uh no one has
chalked up any injuries to coveted
vaccines and so it's being covered by
you know teenage kids automatically get
myocarditis at the rates that we're
seeing now anyway so we're going to go
ahead and cover it anyway so nothing has
ever been actually attributed to any of
the coveted vaccines but uh the concern
was that you would get a vaccine be
injured and then your insurance company
wouldn't cover it and so this bill was
to prevent a an insurance company from
denying you coverage because you
received this experimental vaccine got
it
and do we have we heard any evidence
that this didn't occur well that's
because nobody was ever injured by the
vaccine
#sarcasm
amazing really
okay so you want to make the motion
you'll write the word for me and that's
okay
any more discussion on that
all right now 592 592.
so the uh this this bill it was the
vaccine injury Compensation Program
which was uh modeled after the federal
program but to cover uh vaccines not
covered by
the federal program was trying not to
conflict with that with the issues at
the beginning were preemption and it is
a valid concern with that uh and after
speaking with vaccine injury attorneys
they did assure me that any compensation
that anybody received for any vaccine
injury would work against them in the
federal program so that kind of defeated
the intent behind the bill uh it was to
not interfere with anybody's ability to
participate in that program that program
is horribly inefficient and is it takes
five years on average to to get any kind
of claim and over two-thirds of claims
are rejected without ever seeing the
light of day and so it's a it's a
actually a terrible program uh for most
people and it takes forever for those
that it does end up providing any uh
satisfaction for uh and so this was to
be a state level program uh funding was
was a concern and didn't really nail
down uh the best way to fund the program
and so at this point it's kind of moot
any anyway the damage has been done and
there's no going back and I don't think
there's any way of
there's really no way of going forward
so I'm I have no problem with this thing
never never going into going forward
you're willing to make that motion and
right to blurb yeah uh yeah okay well
that'll be uh unanimous
not that it was a bad idea in the
beginning the bond versus insurance was
a big problem but I didn't say the
funding was perfect trying to find a
funding source
that's all it was I always say every
bill has a grain of truth to it
the devil's in the details
okay
last but not least 1019 salvation
committee to study the replacement of
certain professional licensees with
mandatory minimum liability insurance
requirements I'm glad to make the motion
that this not be recommended for okay
further uh legislation is there anybody
here well I have to say this was a very
creative idea I mean I talk about every
bill has the grain of Truth this is very
creative concept but it did violate one
of John Hunt's rules
and John Hunt's rules of licensure which
you all know by now right the purpose of
how to regulate something and I always
give an example is we had this bill
years ago uh to license contractors
how many you drive in other states and
you all see they got the licensed
contractor and the contractor license in
the state and why do they have licensed
contractors
can they regulate those like can they
actually give continued education to
contractors are they doing it no the
only reason we create licensure is so we
have a vehicle that when you screw up
and you do something bad or harm
somebody or take their money we take
your license away from you
representative yes
so consumer protection is one aspect of
licensure but there's another aspect
that's protectionism for the entrenched
injuries in the industry so we want to
balance those two forces right
absolutely and that's why Joel Winters
that libertarian
Democrat who carried the flag for this
committee to help kill that build when
we had licensed contractors because yes
problem with licensure is now it's
protective of those who have the license
now you have limited the market to how
many people can get in that business A
and B that gives them the power to have
higher rates charge more because they
have that privilege of having the
licensure so it's a balancing act
just the grain of uh you know
interesting idea to this bill I think
it's too cross-cutting it it would upset
every licensed industry so I think we
might want to be a little more careful
how it's applied but but maybe you know
we could apply this to some uh to some
Industries keep this idea in mind as we
go forward maybe it's an option no I
think absolutely it was a very
interesting concept but instead of
having a committee just say let's go
through the books and thumb through the
books and find a license that he needed
to come in with a certain profession
that he could argue that there was no
benefit of the licensure process but
that you would uh you would have the
insurance how I would say that but I
would have to mention that and she's
left she was here all day but she uh she
represents the professional insurance
companies and agents and her comment was
you can cancel an insurance policy the
very next day
so my argument about why we don't need
mandatory auto insurance in this state
is that the drawback is you can get that
insurance get your registration
and then go down to and cancel that
insurance the next day
I've heard that happens in other states
I know but I heard that happens another
stage
that's right exactly so I've heard that
happen in the United States so again the
problem with insurance is how do you you
still need to have some oversight to
ensure that that liability policy was
still in place at all times you know
yeah that's right I think the example
was scuba diving if I remember the and
that they're not licensed but the market
sort of regulates and it's an example of
an industry where people's lives are
maybe at risk very much
but it seems to have worked out in that
industry where you know it's a private
requirement but how much does the people
really take prove to me that you really
have
insurance
how does anybody really know if that
scuba diver really is fully insured on
the spectrum of uh people that are
highly informed to
you know there's probably something you
asked that question when you scuba that
you scuba that's not my thing
about the fully insured lager on the
side of their truck fully injured yeah
right yeah ask for a Certificate of
Insurance
what's the point I always ask for that
Certificate of Insurance before any
contractor that is true representative
Abramson
um
so I wanted to make a point that's why I
put my hand up first
um so I went to see for a living for 12
years and we have both uh obviously
mandatory insurance for merchant ships
to cover any potential damage that they
might do and then of course there's also
the Coast Guard inspectors and then
their OSHA inspectors and by far the the
toughest not only the toughest
inspectors but also the best information
the best education comes from abs abs is
a private company where all the
insurance shipping insurance companies
what is ABS
um I don't remember what it stands for
this was quite a few years ago but is it
they they send their inspectors on with
some really fancy equipment to to to
check everything and what I found is
when insurance companies are providing
coverage that's in the Millions
um that they make absolutely sure that
you're you're on top of everything and
they are way ahead of governmental
agencies and inspecting things and the
standards are also higher at least in
shipping
um
so my thought is if you know if if it's
good enough for business why isn't it
good enough for individuals I would much
at some point when you contract with a
private professional you've got to look
for some piece of paper and it's either
going to say licensed by the state or
private insured and and I thought that
this study committee was worth going
forward and looking into and look you
know opening up this can of worms
because I thought that we might get
better standards by having literally
having private insurance companies that
could operate in any state and bring
them bring in their expertise from other
states and other countries to use scuba
as an example
um scuba is an underwriter's laboratory
and these uh others IEEE they all do
different types of certification it's
private building codes that we have at
the state level we're originally private
building codes most of these codes were
developed privately and the the private
sector doesn't just do a better job of
keeping costs down as I've said it does
a very good job of keeping quality up
once we
set things up so that the incentives are
in place to favor quality and Longevity
and whatnot
um so I felt that the study committee
was definitely worthwhile because there
was a potential for certain
professionals deal with life and death
issues
um and because that was a public safety
issue I felt that it was worth opening
up this can of worms to see if we could
get better quality than just the generic
go in take the test meet certain state
requirements and then get a piece of
paper and in some cases that's that's
been a false false sense of security for
consumers I think that if they have to
carry Insurance in order to do business
Architects engineers and so forth that
at least the consumer has someone to go
back to not just here's a piece of paper
that they've taken a test I've done a
lot of Occupational licensing over my
career but but isn't that just a piece
of paper that insurance company said yes
they did pay the policy and it's no on a
certain date isn't that just a piece of
paper because I'm sure that if you got
canceled you're not going to hand that
to the person who's asking to show me
your proof of insurance
you're not going to hand them a the one
that said the letter that says have been
canceled you're going to hand them the
letter that said I got the policy then
that would be fraud claiming so that's
another thing that can you you can get
recourse through the courts by claiming
fraud that they said that they had
insurance and they didn't have it's one
thing on top of another uh versus if
it's just a state license well you get a
state license it carries on for so many
years that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's no they're going to shut you down
that's the whole poison they will shut
you down
excuse me representative Bartlett thank
you Mr chair
um representative Abramson brings up a
whole lot of different things when with
the examples that he's using ocean
marine for one thing is a very different
product
um
the rates that go into an insurance
policy are based on the cost of writing
the policy and the cost of paying claims
and then they're allowed to make a
profit because you don't want to write
with an insurance company that is not
profitable
if you decided that you wanted the
insurance company to do all of the
um the qualifications for someone that
they're writing as a
instead of Licensing you would also
increase the cost dramatically for
instance boiler Machinery policies you
have to have if you have a boiler in
your business you have to have a boiler
Machinery policy two-thirds of the cost
of whether Machinery is just for
inspections
so that'll start to give you an idea of
what goes into those rates
I'm feeling like this this discussion is
going way further than
really necessary but trying to use an
insurance policy instead of Licensing
um you're you're talking about two
different things entirely insurance
company can also just you know they can
underwrite they can decide whether
you're acceptable or not for various
reasons maybe they don't write
carpenters in this state anymore so
if you're a carpenter you're not going
to get into policy there's just so much
that goes into this that this
bill would not meet the needs that we
have
eventually say that if we were to pass
this any license any license we got rid
of any profession we did this the
insurance probably will go up in price
so you have the the negative effect of
actually raising the costs for that
industry
representative Yemen I just had one
quick point the uh there is a problem
with the bill it requires three members
of the Senate to be president and it's
hard enough to get one of them to show
up to a commission so that's a problem
okay you have the last hurray Max so I
when I was working as a merchant Mariner
I talked to a woman who worked as a
nurse and she was I guess two classes
away from getting her MD
and she told me about the case of a
heart surgeon who was licensed
um and he had paperwork up the yin yang
but he was not competent to work and she
noticed that he was being transferred
around from hospital to hospital
hospital no one would say anything
phenomenal reputation everyone said
wonderful things about him
long story short turned out the guy was
not only making mistakes at a first-year
medical student wouldn't wouldn't make
it's operating on the wrong side of the
heart
um and made a lot of errors and it was
killing some of his patients
um she found out that he was a fraud but
he had the license he had the paperwork
he once he was caught everyone found out
it was on the hush hush he went up to
his office locked his door and killed
himself
they went back through his whole 30-plus
year career he'd killed over three he'd
killed over 2 000 patients over his
career but he had the piece of paper the
entire time
so the the you know it's one thing for
one state agency after another in one
hospital after another to just allow it
we have doctors in New England
who go lose their license in one state
and they go to another state my friend
Kelly Deo died because she was being
over prescribed prescription drugs
mostly opioids and other types of things
she died licensed doctor he lost his
license in New Hampshire he was now
licensed up in Maine piece of paper is a
false sense of security that can get
people killed
that's a credentialing issue with the
hospitals they didn't do their job and
evidently that's a a hot burner issue
right now should cmcs
you won okay John you can have the
lessons thank you Mr Speaker
um I get to have the last word
everybody knows these these are my
binders this is one biennium's worth of
bills amendments and notes
this is my third term where I've been in
Commerce
now you know what my library looks like
and mine's as bad as
the minority leaders
that's only one year that's only one
year
this is this is this is 2021
one year
I just thought to let you know
and we're not really busy this is bienna
we're only moderately busy
so The Best Is Yet To Come thank you and
see ya okay we'll see you all next
Monday you're going to be here Max next
Wednesday
okay good
we're gonna exec all these bills on next
Wednesday Wednesday morning next
Wednesday
all right thank you all very much